und über die situation in der ukraine
wollen wir jetzt auch mit erich vaart
sprechen er ist brigadegeneral der
bundeswehr ag und ehemaliger militär
politischer berater im bundeskanzleramt
guten morgen herzlich willkommen guten
morgen frau von waldenfels wie schätzen
sie die militärische lage in der ukraine
aktuell ein was beobachten sie dort bei
der kriegsführung
also im moment ist es so dass im süden
die russischen streitkräfte sehr
erfolgreich unterwegs sind also die
schwarzmeerküste wird quasi komplett
kontrolliert sie stehen kurz vor odessa
und sie haben es ist ihnen auch gelungen
eine landverbindung herzustellen aus der
krim in den dom bass die sie versuchen
zu erraten zu verbreitern die ukraine
wollen das natürlich verhindern kämpfen
dort auch aber es werden jetzt auch
kräfte der ukraine abgezogen aus dem
südosten in die hauptstadt kiew weil
dort so im moment der militärische
schwerpunkt gesehen wird und die russen
greifen auch von osten mit einer
kolonne gehen sie in richtung der
hauptstadt vor
das ganze offensichtlich nicht in einem
zügigen tempo aber ich bewerte das eben
auch so dass sie sich damit bewusst auch
zeit lassen auch diese masken oder aus
dem norden also diese meldungen die sind
unfähig die logistik stimmt nicht liegen
gebliebene fahrzeuge zum teil stimmt das
aber ich glaube sie bereiten sich
einfach systematisch für diesen kampf in
und umkehr vor und lassen auch zu
deswegen spielen sie russen auch auf
zeit das eben zivilisten diese
großstädte weitgehend verlassen können
über so genannte humanitäre korridore
dann nehmen wir mal den fall an putin
besetzt tatsächlich die ganze ukraine
setzt eine pro russische regierung in
kiew ein was für eine situation würden
wir dann eigentlich im land erleben
also militärisch betrachtet reichen die
kräfte der russen für eine gesamt
besetzung der ukraine definitiv nicht
aus für mich ist der militärische fokus
ganz klar im südosten der ukraine
sie haben mir jetzt fast 180.000 mann
drin
und sie brauchen sehr viele kräfte auch
wenn es dazu kommt zum kampf in diesen
bebauten gelände in diesen urbanen
zentren des südostens brauchen sie dafür
sehr viel manpower und das gilt vor
allem für tiere die hier ja die
politische regierung die leitung sitzt
der militärische generalstab die
nachrichtendienste die
kommunikationsnetze der ukraine mich und
darauf bereiten sich jetzt die russen
mit schwerpunkt vor und das ist eine
sehr starke herausforderung ist auch
wenn es dazu kommt eine der blutigsten
geschichten die man im krieg erleben
kann also oben warfare also kampf in
bebautem gebiet wo ja immer zivilisten
tangiert sind wo man als angreifer auch
eine zigfache überlegenheit braucht wir
kennen ja die beispiele aus bagdad zum
beispiel beirut rpo das kann sehr
fürchterlich werden welche die russen
lassen sich aber da aus meiner sicht
bewusst zeit weil sie eben auch
innenpolitischen den druck haben viele
russen sehen in der ukraine neben ein
bruder volk und das ist nicht irgend
etwas anderes was man dabei kämpft
insofern muss man das mit einkalkulieren
wir haben heute schon darüber berichtet
seelands gerhard offenbar nicht mehr auf
einen sofortigen nato-beitritt und will
auch möglicherweise über den status von
ostgebieten verhandeln ist das ein
mögliches lösung szenario
also ich denke auch das sind wirklich
gute nachrichten dass man jetzt in
richtung einer politischen lösung geht
und man kann nur hoffen dass das
funktioniert diese escala torische
rhetorik ist auf beiden seiten auch in
manchen medien des westens mit blick auf
putin das ist alles wenig hilfreich es
gibt nur eine politische lösung in dem
ganzen und ich sehe da erste ansätze und
man kann nur hoffen dass das erfolgreich
ist erich fahrt war das brigadegeneral
der bundeswehr ag und ehemaliger militär
politischer berater im bundeskanzleramt
dankeschön für diese einordnung vielen
dank vielen dank frau von waldenfels